what up reject nation greg and john here
today we are going to watch episode three
of stranger things four so excited for this
ladies and gentlemen as always full-length
watch long as we sync up with the time code for
stranger things or for super sexy rejects over at
our patreon cover a whole bunch of shows some of
them with exclusive reaction highlights included
if you don't want to do that leave a like and a
comment with your thoughts on today's episode also
subscribe and click that notification bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next episode
is up on the channel lastly then boys at prepper
when you guys are in need of editing help they are
the boys to contact don't over book them though
because we still need some space oh yeah but
that's a good prompt for
them to have let's do this
polarizer back in the game love me some paul
ryzer there were no signs of any attacker
no bruises it's as if her attacker was a ghost
does this remind you of anything doctor no
doesn't i've never seen a port like this
men like you who created this problem in
the first place we need guns lots of guns
here's a photo at a roller skating rink taken
just days ago 11 is dead i'm not convinced are
you saying i'm helping her is that what you're
saying am i getting suspiciously defensive
i i don't know what you're talking about
why are you taking that box those are peter's
old school projects you do not need those
sam do something come on go all nobody on them
sam i have been theorizing since the first trailer
that paul ryder was going to die
this season oh boy i hope not
just does it seem my way it seems like he's
got to that's that's the best way that he can
go out with dignity angela angela do you know
where you are angela angela who's the boss
usually the third episode
he does third time's a char
don't worry 11 your problems are only about
to get better i'm shedding and [__] but that
future prom queen is gonna be fine i mean it was
just like rubber wheels plastic oh prom queen nice
little nod building up i mean the grand scheme of
things just a little blip that's a funny word man
liberty
kids like risotto oh i make a good
risotto you're just like hey murray
so i thought hey you know what why don't i drop
in and say hello to my old friends this thing
came in you passed me the olive oil which one
turns out i have to go to a conference tomorrow
in alaska so do eskimos like still live in igloos
or uh like living in the suburbs yeah who is this
this girl got smacked in the head today at the
roller rink snack it was a plastic skate no i was
like rubber rubber rubber remember anyway she she
looks like she's gonna be fine she's totally fine
she didn't look fine oh god i sense tension
is it the risotto everyone hates the risotto
it's risotto he's smacking dude
i still have no idea who he
i just want is say i ship murray
and joyce all the way team moise
paul ryder is going to pop off her under the bed
now these visuals are nuts
so nuts such a nightmare
and the color scheme like oh
mr miyagi
we're gearing up preparing for the hunt
and we're not killers like eddie and we
just want to talk to him get him to admit his
crime yeah little friendly neighborhood chat
i like side bullies we always laugh at everything
if you're not up to this you can go home
there's no judgment you'll still be one
of us all right because you got the winning
point that's all that keeps you as one of us
delivery service maybe you shouldn't
just burst in guys yeah serious
knock at least so before that happens we
need to find vecna kill him and prove your
innocence that's all dustin we've actually
been through this kind of thing before i mean
they have mine was more human flesh based
and theirs was more smoke related but
meta
humor ambi lamps oh yeah
i thought with it when you observe the
details like the hand and the freaking arms
you were scared of me no no no that's not that's
that's not true i was surprised it doesn't change
anything it doesn't matter i care for you so much
but you don't you don't love me anymore what dude
you never say it you can't even write it mike from
mike from mike from mike you can't let these mouth
breathers ruin you ruin us i mean they're nobodies
and you're a superhero tell her you love her baby
yeah hi is uh jane hopper live here what is
this about you may or may not be aware of
an incident that happened last night involving
jane at the wrinkle mania that was an accident
just tell us where you're taking her one of
the cuffs really necessary ah she being taken
by and they've probably got some higher
ups yeah they're just disguised as cops
ah the good old days why are you adults
always gone when the kids need you most
i think you did the right thing this way what
they play too much nintendo eat too much junk food
smoke some ganja pound some beers experiment
sexually i mean thanks for opening up murray
so as you're acting if my pilot gets the money
you will bring it to me in this plane tomorrow
then you can hit your right with him back to your
country great so he's a criminal well of course
unless do you want to do this job gandhi ideally
sure you miss that plane tomorrow i am still rich
and you're still stuck in kamchatka so
whatever it is you're planning american
let's get to it yes i'll pull up i like this
actor i saw chrissy leaving miss kelly's office
if you saw a monster you wouldn't go
to the police they'd never believe you
but you might go to your shrink shrinks
are the enemy yes scientology was right
there's just something i want to check on first
something you maybe want to share with the rest
of us i don't want to waste your time it's a real
shot in the dark yeah okay are you out of your
mind flying solo with this vector creep on the
loose no it's too dangerous you need someone to oh
oh my god is it going to be dancer gotta loop
back around us ladies we'll stick together
unless you think we need you to protect us
i'm so sick of this woke [__] yeah take it back
to season one just a little boy's club that's it
yeah buddy
matchka
must be right on top of the creole house
so he just kind of like connects to it like
a hive mind yeah this is like his cerebro
yeah yeah like yeah nightmare to go to that awful
place i'll just tell them i fell again i slipped
we're looking for eddie munson he's in
this band lukas what the hell we're just
trying to find eddie man well you
have eyes don't you he's not here
oh hey man smash the guitar
on him where is i don't know
this is not the way to go
about it send him to kamchatka
he's calling her out looking for andy
maybe he got him where do we find this
dustin every season needs an alpha bully yep
jane hopper okay yes i see her now it looks
like she's still being processed okay so uh
i mean what does that mean exactly it
means they're putting her in the system now
chills
this is not like maybe painful [__]
hopper doesn't [__] around anymore
oh buddy
damn victor creel escape from pendrist asylum
and that he's the one running around
hawkins committing all these murders
pretty much victor committed the eyeball
murders like way back in the 50s 59.
these murders pre-date uh 11 and
the upside down by about 30 years
back to the library could we get the keys to the
basement archives of course give me one second did
i come off mean or condescending or something
no right sorry it's just you seem annoyed
do you have a minute to talk um yeah
of course of course here at my home
your temporary insanity earlier today when
you basically threw yourself at nancy are
you implying that i still have a thing
for nance no i'm not implying i'm stating
i was just trying to protect a friend you're like
bright red he's written no i'm not i don't want
to talk about it i'll punch you so hard in your
face that your teeth will fall back out oh too far
not cool sorry oh no one wants a protective
platonic friend that's not true they can fend
for themselves did chrissy mention anything you
wouldn't want me talking to any other students
about you right if i were dead and it would help
catch the killer then yeah i most definitely would
can i use the bathroom sure up the stairs to the
left in the attic that's where she keeps the files
smooth what'd she say nothing but
just drive nothing steve drive
man no one's home so now what we keep looking
oh where the hell is sinclair
dustin lucas where the hell have you
been just listen are you guys looking
for eddie yeah and we found him no thanks to
you you found him he's at a boathouse uncle no
you're so behind it's ridiculous okay just
meet us at the school we'll explain later
i can't i think some real
bad shit's about to go down
what are you talking about what bad oh
guys shut the [__] up never be quiet
what the hell were you doing
i was i was looking for clues
clues what freshmen think you
sherlock holmes or something
that was funny give it here josh yeah yeah
i found one what a clue a clue don't
say it i know where eddie's hiding
more than a clue mislead them bro
that is exact type of information
they're looking for that's the solution
here come the men in black are
you transporting a jane hopper
yeah what is this i'll take her off your hands
what if this only had to do with hitting angela
yeah this goes all the way to the top brass oh man
hey kiddo
welcome to alaska oh god this is spring
does hopper not know there's
a demogorgon there i guess he
mustn't unless they just don't
need to tell us that right now
guys you're so cool
oh no
oh in the cold too higher
hello dr gordon stop oh yeah
yup yup yup let's go full
gerald's game let's just do it
oh they got any shirt
i don't like any level of gloving you
don't you don't want to build the magic
i wanted to make sure that you knew that steve and
i are just friends like platonic with a capital p
in case that's adding any tension between us
may i remind you that we are looking
for information on dark wizards
if someone's gonna write about
that it's gonna be these weirdos
ah elvis cloned by aliens you never know season
five how's it going huggins according to several
insiders victor believed his house was haunted by
an ancient demon victor allegedly hired a priest
to exercise the demon from his home pretty
novel for the 50s exodus wasn't even out yet
i mean it sounds pretty insane it just
didn't go public because the plea bargain
the records were sealed what if
a demon did invade victor's home
holy [__] founder yeah not just chrissy
smile fred was seeing miss kelly too am i next
better got a good dicer
horribly hawkins is in danger
each time it returns it comes back
stronger smarter deadlier
a war is coming to hawkins
where you at freak ha ha good on you lucas
smarts you sure eddie was here yeah i'm positive
let's check around the back
there are good people brave friends i know it's
not fair to ask more of you but i wouldn't be here
if i didn't think this was the only way i don't
have my powers what if i told you there was a way
why have you been holding out you're gonna kill
angela weeks again he's gonna disintegrated
her on the spot developing the means to
restore your abilities what the hell dude
you are proactive but there are others
who don't believe in you who think you are
i believe they're wrong i believe you're the cure
but you should know there is a very real
possibility this program fails and if it does
you will never see your friends again my friends
in hawkins are they in danger yeah i'd say
i'm afraid your friends and hawkins are very much
can i see fred's file she's got the same symptoms
it's a lot for anyone and it's okay to not be okay
so you say the word and i
will take you right back home
or come with me now come
with me now my great speech
please pack the food get the waffles for the road
we need you jonathan
i thought i thought he was stalking
the other guy yeah what gives
i was just hap hoping it was goofy maximilian
all righty just a few more to go but 11 uprising
yes 11 rising 11 2.0 fantastic speech that riser
is definitely dead yeah yeah yeah yeah there's no
way he's gonna save your moment like this without
it coming with any punishment it's like the
biggest most cathartic like you know boost in uh
morale yeah man uh but i like what they're doing
with 11. it's she's her character has always had a
a struggle with accepting herself that's a big
part of her journey and the search for identity
you know and then what if it's always been like no
just accept everything that was kind of you were
born into like what if you can accept that and
realize that that curse has always been the gift
and the key to being a hero this whole
time the key to being a force of good
that you have to go through that to be
the force of good as opposed to like in
season two trying to shift her identity around
a lot and going down a different path and then
now here trying to just be like super duper
normal this whole thing um that yeah it's like
she has a struggle of acceptance of who she
is and and dealing with her past and that's
something that i think can be a cool showdown to
occur with creole or uh vechna but vechna vachna
that would be the ultimate twist and pull off
the mask to some swedish guy yeah uh that vecna
and and her and you know she has to deal with
her own stuff i thought it was a little cheesy
with uh it was like a rewarding kind of like
action hero cheese to me like what if i told
you i developed a program yeah yeah it's already
a potion and i did this in my 80s computer at home
it's been so dark to have a moment like that
i'm just some like cheesy montage of already
developing something it did feel like a nice
act break or something like that because yeah
everything else has developed at a pretty uh
you know steady and deliberate pace alongside
everything else and then this was i it's you know
the answer to the question and yeah he establishes
it could not work and things could go very
wrong okay however yes basically this is
exactly what we need but better so yeah i mean
you'll be even stronger yeah yeah so it does
break the reality of the moment a little bit but
yeah not in a way that that vexed me or anything
like that because of course we want to see eleven
come back bigger and better and we know that there
will be consequences to that and that won't be
the entire solution to everything that's going on
yeah yeah it's it's like she was born as 11
or at least raises 11 knows that her her mom
named her jane should go by the ingenity of jane
and now it's i think it's about putting the
two together now for her yeah you know jalebin
yes but yeah yeah merging both identities and
taking the things that she does have that she
has amassed of a normal life and of real human
connections but also bruce wayne is batman batman
is bruce smith yeah but really both of them
thriving in harmony alongside each other yeah
yeah something along those lines so that was
great paul ryser really welcomed return here
um this is more of like a momentum forward episode
you know yeah of a lot of plot advancements lucas
being conflicted i was about to be pissed at him
when i was like oh [__] is he about to is he
about to just kind of give in to peer pressure
i didn't know where he would mislead them smart
mislead because it's also a reasonable location
where he could assume someone was hiding out yeah
um yeah these bullies well not even really
they have like a bully attitude but they're not
i mean they're kind of bullies they're gonna
get up the band they have a motive here they're
trying to get revenge for the death of the guy's
girlfriend yeah they're they're not the social
outcast bullies who are mean to everyone but
yeah yeah clearly they look down on everybody
beneath their tear up between their athletic
abilities yeah we are the top of the food chain
and we are the gold standards of high school
a thousand percent yeah but i really like that
like i really like the way they've drawn the
conflicts both with like lucas dealing with
his new friend group and the old friend group
and the awkwardness of navigating that as well
as like mike and eleven like we were talking last
episode about you know not seeing mike as much as
seeing finn wolfhard but i thought this brought
me closer to that like i really liked their
scene together too of confrontation her saying
why why won't you say that you love me and him
kind of insisting that he will but also uh you
know taking issue with her lies and and the way
in which she wouldn't feel comfortable coming
to him even though she knows that there's a
lot of common ground and i think the the distance
they've driven between them and the perspectives
that they both express feel natural and not too
contri like i feel like it would be very easy
to fall into contrivance and since they are young
characters who are coming of age i feel like you
know these are written by adults and sometimes
the adults don't have as much of that you know
foothold in that walk of life but i thought it
was pretty authentic here on both counts you know
well mike is the first season with mike he
he really was like the lead kid of that of
that show um i don't know if he's like the
definitive lead character but i this is
my favorite season of mike is still the first
season and he was the one who was like more
the hopeful optimist and the kid you identified
with the most out of them all and at least on an
emotional standpoint and he you know he saw eleven
as the only one who took real compassion upon her
and as the students have progressed they keep
having these moments of conflict with them of like
something about your attitude and the way you're
being like i don't like the way you're being
yeah you have to keep having this recurring
thing with him and he just gets like defensive
yeah like upset and uh and i i don't
really i feel like the arc of him is
is not as like clearly defined for me i would
agree with that uh as but he's always uh he's
always a pleasant presence but he's he doesn't
really he feels like definitely part more of
the ensemble now than he was initially as
like one of the main leads yeah you know
and i don't know i just can't tell love and he
he loves what's up with the men in this season
just being like oh nancy i don't know if i love
you or i do love you i can't tell you though
what i'm really doing and mike like i can't write
the word i could write a whole letter but i can't
write love mike you know yeah and you can't even
tell her there just reassure her and it's weird
because like i believed him and so i was like
what's keeping you from just go with that one
step for clearly the intent is there maybe it's
when he lost she lost her powers just wasn't the
same after that true love's kissing infatuation
that's right i only liked you for your powers
now you're just like everyone else is a girl
here yeah yeah you just want me for my wit
that was great i really like max's performance
or that actresses i really think her
performance has been very solid interesting
trajectory they're doing it for her where
it's like the setup that they have for each
character here is you've got to come to terms
of your trauma to beat these guys yeah
to beat fact no you got to come to terms
like how do i speed up acceptance
that's what life is like you know identifying
problems and going how do i fast track myself
to living functionally really bold move
they kill off max i yeah and i mean i could
definitely see it being a big impactful
thing especially i mean you never know
it seems like this episode left off with a pretty
hefty it seems like the next episode must focus
pretty heavily on her and what they're giving her
is pretty significant i think like those scenes
her scenes have been especially affecting to me
and so uh yeah i it's funny i feel like we've got
we should have like a bingo card going or like
a betting pool going of who's gonna die this
we should have a deadpool for who's gonna die in
season four uh i could see it for max i hope not
but i think they could do something really
powerful and impactful with that i thought
that they were jonathan and what's the stoner
guy saying argyle our guy i thought they were
pretty funny this time around the most i enjoyed
them so far yeah so this they're the steve of
uh california still waiting for jonathan to
come like something hefty to the plot yes
see our girls doing the heavy lifting yeah i'm
enjoying i enjoy them they're more like funny
comedic relief yeah and it's fascinating to me
what they've done with robin because i remember
robin being more of like the cooler anti-social
girl yeah and this time around she just like
doesn't shut up yeah they're bringing out her
her geek her geek word vomiting yeah erotic
it's very different from how she was uh in the
last season like she's not like she was the one
with the scoops ahoy she was the one who was
like she seemed smarter than them and was the
most level-headed and it was the coolest one
yeah uh so to to have heard this time around
which is so neurotic especially like any given
situation just doesn't know how to socialize
i don't know what it is maybe some acting choices
like i'm actually attracted to nancy and here's
why i'm like being the way i am they keep making
me wonder about everyone's attractions this
season yeah it's like everyone's going through
relationship problems or there's like a bunch
of reasons to be like wait are they vibing and
are they vibing i don't know but yeah there's
a sort of a change in robin but i'm curiou like
i'm curious to see if they if if they're making a
point out of that or oria if it is just a choice
but i liked their little scene together and i
thought it was fun to get the yeah like searching
through the old newspapers and figuring out that
the shot in the dark actually is like as much
as that is economics of time that they're like i
gotta do this quick research and then we find out
that was the right research to do it still felt
pretty nice and hopper this episode like with
everything uh in russia and his buddy there and
the whole breaking his chains yeah like i like how
they've kept that like on this very slow steady
physical build build-up because all certain things
feel very sort of fast-moving and very intense
like you have this build with hopper to this
probably very precarious escape of some kind
of sure yeah like they're able to balance that
too and just the the stuff in russia is just so
desolate and so harsh like you could really
feel the bite of the cold and everything
that's right they're in russia yeah pilot
in alaska yeah yeah okay get in my mouth
right you're confused with the snow snow snowy
landscapes yeah yeah but i don't know even that
cannot go according to planet course not it
would be terrible if you did yeah just like
polarizer shows i got hop around don't even
in fact i'm gonna make his ankle even better
than it was before working on a machine it's
called stem cell research and 3d printing yep
all risers skeleton key for all problems all
right guys well here we are stranger things
um keep a lookout for our next reaction and
we will should chat with y'all soon soon
olivier haimlin yo thanks for being back here
at this point in time we're almost at a million
subs it's great to have people like you showing
your support and still wanting these exclusive
patreon day shots and last time we talked about
how your first name meant olive tree which is
beautiful but we are looking up in real time what
your last name means hamlin hamlin all right oh
dang this is crazier check this out everyone
okay the hamline family lived in gluckersteia
uh their name however is a local
reference of old french derivation
it stems from the old french root hamel indicating
that the original bearer of the name once worked
at an outlying farm which was dependent
upon a main village dude that is so cool
i understood all of that and
all of that relates to you
this is the freaking you're you're you worked
near someone's farm dude you're an olive tree
near a farm that someone worked out and owns man
that's like a perfect progression right there you
could be an olive farm that's how bountiful
you are olivier hamelin his name's french
olivier
but no that's german uh but i don't i don't
know if we could the french don't like us
hey we don't have very many french viewers
i know there's a reason why yeah because
i have a real issue with french
people oh i do too my issue is
i want to be just like all of them all every
french person they don't let me and they
every time you try to set foot in the country they
don't let me appropriate yeah you know well dude
i tried for the longest time i used to go by ryan
right here and then i tried to change my name to
frenchie and they wouldn't they wouldn't want me
they wouldn't accept you i was like you racist
[__] yeah why can't i why can't i can't i
identify as french i choose to identify as french
you're french to me i accept you i'm romantic i
got a big wee-wee like a baguette it's like a bag
sticking out of a bicycle basket i believe in free
prostitutes yeah absolutely that's what the french
have right free prostitute free prostitutes is
it weirdly it's really totally contradictory
the charity process they get to write off the
time against their uh you know french taxes
hello i hope i can be accepted into your french
family and one day go by gregory hamlin pull
some strings bruh you're a good guy you're a
great guy you should name a laboratory after
you or something or a farm in france this went so
good this went about as good as could be expected
christina aguilera